[Musique]
toutes les variables et tous les postes
diplomatiques américains sont mis sous
haute alerte aperture de m une fois le
grand absent la place tahrir aujourd'hui
sont les frères musulmans il n'y a pas
de renouveau y'a rien la foule scande la
france est derrière ben ali qu'ils
soutiennent cet ancien régime dans ton
mauvais parents
président déchu est en fuite la france
ne veut pas d'un petit de mal
[Musique]
après 18 jours de révolte le peuple a
finalement obtenu ce qu'ils réclamaient
la démission du président moubarak
la liberté d'expression semble
contagieuse en egypte et les égyptiens
ont soif de changement tout indique et
tous confirment que kadhafi serait mort
ce qui concerne ce bombardement ils
révèlent et bien eu lieu
selon les informations même de l'état
affirmant que s'est produit à 8h15
précisément semaine cette fibre et
doussain en quoi elle est cruciale cette
élection à quoi les pets historique même
est ce qui est le conservateur
réussiront à percer l'île de montréal on
verra jack layton a misé sur les mots
choix et changement les résultats
torontois et ontariens ce soir vaudront
leur pesant d'or mais nous pouvons
maintenant ça faisait à peine deux
heures que le ministre est descendu de
l'avion qui s'empressait d'annoncer ce
qui était de plus en plus prévisible de
nous retirer officiellement de kyoto les
résidents qui sont pas au bout de leurs
peines
il ne suffit que d'un coup d'oeil pour
comprendre le cauchemar que vivent des
dizaines de personnes en montérégie
si la pluie cesse on nous dit que le
niveau de la rivière richelieu pourrait
se stabiliser
la vue de telles images d'horreur vous
devinerez que le bilan des victimes
n'est toujours que provisoire la terre a
tremblé et très très fort il faut dire
aussi que depuis des années on parlait
de ce grand tremblement terre on avait
l'impression qu'il s'en venait ce grand
c vous méritez mieux de mon rôle était
jack layton s'est donc éteint chez lui
la nuit dernière à toronto
[Applaudissements]